all right welcome everybody to the pill
pod
this week's intro comes to you courtesy
of
tf prodigy 2. thank you tf prodigy 2.
i kind of wondered what his name meant
tf prodigy like team fortress is the
only thing i can think of
he was very good at team fortress as a
child team fortress 2 that would explain
the two
fully leaning into his identity
anyway he didn't like my intro last time
which is a bit meandering so
i crowdsourced it and he just gave me an
intro to read so we're gonna read this
welcome to the pillpod your weekly
philosophy and critical theory podcast
you can find our regularly scheduled
bonus episodes and content on our
patreon
that's right
also
tf prodigy 2 you forgot to mention we
release every friday
and we don't call them bonus episodes we
call them exclusive episodes so other
than that
thank you very much for the help but he
is right because he's if he's a long
time listener he knows that there was a
time when you would just call them bonus
interviews if we did some interviews so
well the interviews i do consider bonus
because they are bonuses in addition to
our regularly scheduled pill part so
there's different tiers there's so
there's there's exclusive and then
there's also bonus
there's exclusive pill pods and that's
an exclusive bonus well we have that too
that's a
bonus interview only on the patreon so
maybe what if it's a patreon only
interview if it's a patreon only bonus
interview then that would be exclusive
bonus content right exactly
okay got it
quit rocking the boat
[Music]
we are joined today by our number one
guest at long last
lit vid
the long-awaited richard hi guys the
other the other victor as i like to
think of him yeah no it's nice it's very
strange to have a to be confronted with
other victors um it's actually one
when i've met pills i don't know if i've
ever mentioned this to the audience but
the first time i'm at pills he told me
like to my shock it's never happened
he's like oh i have three other friends
named victor
victor you are still you are still in my
phone as victor iv
where is am i really lydvik is in my
phone as victor
originally now it's a little more
manageable
it's just two right like like do you
talk to the other two victors well one
accused me of being illuminati so he cut
me off and the others at the bottom of
the keyhole as far as i know so it's
just the two victors remaining i
remember i remember when you told me as
i hung out with uh with these guys more
eventually i remember uh pills telling
me oh like you've you've moved up in the
ranks i now consider you victory three
and it's like oh now they're making me
sound like an [ __ ] anyway he's like
you're victory
this is lit vic which is still victor
too though not the name of an eastern
european dj as it might sound but uh
shocker in this case he actually is an
eastern european dj yeah i've dabbled
yeah yeah damn
not not he's never dj okay no i'm an
english phd student yeah so my main
research is actually on globalization in
the renaissance but i also have some
background on american literature which
is what we'll be talking about today so
phd candidate u of t
down the road and uh usually we start
out with some news stories but
literally nothing happened in canada not
in this country this week so we're just
gonna not a damn thing not yeah thing
you're telling me
boring
in all seriousness though i did i did
feel like uh chantello bear that she's
the cbc like one of the political
commentators she had she did say like
you know and then i thought her take was
the best in an election that no one
wanted nobody got what they wanted
oh yeah like no no party got any of like
accomplished any of the goals they had
and no one wanted the election and it's
like no one got like like every
disappointment all around
no one gets anything and there's
something kind of satisfying about
seeing that happen yeah to our listeners
uh who know we're canadian uh but aren't
from canada and demand that we give them
a thorough breakdown i'm not gonna give
them a thorough version this is the
thorough breakdown everything is exactly
the same the party that i wanted to win
gained one seat and the party that i
dislike lost two there you go there's
your thorough breakdown congratulations
and if you'd like a more thorough
breakdown
i would prefer not to
the first one
this is the first one
let's not overuse it first of many
um so specific or today we're talking
about literature which is why litvic is
here not his only area of expertise but
it's in the name so you know that he's
an authority on it
uh we're talking about herman melville
and specifically the short story of
bartleby which i highly recommend it was
really [ __ ] funny and it's only
my edition was like what 35 pages
yeah it was a good one i really i also
really enjoyed it the scrivener i had to
look up i learned what a scrivener was
which is uh
interesting i get like it's one of those
things that today you're like well we
just have like typewriters and computers
but
basically they were just like people who
copied legal documents right so like
when someone would write them and like
you need to distribute copies of the
legal documents they just worked in law
offices and were just copying [ __ ] all
day right that's what it was a human
photocopier yeah you could call them a
copyist if it's more broad i guess
scriftner is specific to uh legal
documents well zizek famously has the
shirt and he came up or this story came
up in our episode on beyonce han which
was pillpot 27 i checked but it's also
referenced by
the liz agambin heart and negri
jijek of course so we got a few
philosophical references that kind of do
whatever they want to this story they
bugger it
um am i missing anybody i think that's
all
jimmy was i don't know if he referenced
the story directly but it was deeply
inspired apparently by melville and
this kind of absurdist slash proto
existentialist approached the world and
you can also see it in his style
especially his short stories like the
guests uh i really had like strong
guest vibes throughout this
and it's pretty [ __ ] funny even
though it was written in what
1850s or 60s yeah oh 100 yeah so
bartleby is the
not the main character the it's the the
story is told from the perspective of
bartleby's boss so we have the class
antagonism reading into there
he never speaks unless spoken to
pretty much his only documented words
are i prefer not to even though the
narrator does account for him saying
certain other words the narrator is his
boss but is also concerned about him out
of christian charity
um he doesn't eat anything he sits in
this legal office and copies stuff out
all day ginger nut cakes
ginger nut cakes whatever those are
no family or friends to speak of so he's
like a humanity-free
human yeah i i didn't want to say i did
love that [ __ ] secret because i liked
this story a lot i thought it was
hilarious and but his boss just gets
uptight he's like well if you're not
gonna leave my [ __ ] office and let me
do my job then i'm just gonna [ __ ]
let you have the office and move
somewhere entirely new and that'll
[ __ ] show you you [ __ ]
yeah
it's genuinely a fun story right like
don't think like if you think of
melville you'll probably think oh 200
pages on how to hunt and kill and
process a whale like this is
legitimately really funny
not quite a laugh a minute but
observance uh and it's quick i really
yeah it's funny the dry matter-of-fact
way that he describes these extremely
absurd characters creates this really
comic effect that i quite enjoy
yeah so before we turn to the various
interpretations of the story um i
thought we'd get to something that none
of us know well except our guests here
at least i think unless you guys are
secretly melville scholars
but we got lit vic here who can speak to
the context and to melville as a dude
who i've always seen as kind of a
psychologist author and which is
particularly important given his context
in
the early
moments of uh american capitalism kind
of zeitgeisting its way into the world
and this is someone who's writing at
kind of the time when that's appearing
and as a psychologist i don't know why
don't i just kick it to you victor is
that is that a good way to portray that
and is there anything else you'd say and
why and what's the significance of
melville in literature yeah for sure so
i mean we can consider him a
psychologist now many of his relatives
actually thought that he was a little
bit crazy like they kept trying to get
him like normal government jobs and
everything and he kept just wanting to
like write crazy existentialist stories
about whales and scriveners but um
yeah so he he lived in the 19th century
he was actually born in new york city
where the story takes place bartleby
and he had quite the resume so before
becoming a writer melville was also um
he worked at a bank he worked as a
whaler
he allegedly lived among cannibals for a
couple of months in the pacific he was
actually known as the man who lived
among the cannibals to his peers so
that tells you something about his
reputation at the time
and uh street and on what some island or
something
yeah
from wall street to the cannibals the
full range of um
the 19th century experience yeah
and um
he it's it's so it's it's worth noting
he had al already published his epic
moby dick about two years before he
wrote bartleby the scrivener
and around that time his reputation
wasn't really great he wasn't critically
regarded like melville's own reputation
as a writer and moby dick's reputation
as like the great american novel really
only picked up steam in the 20th century
because
in some ways his writing and his outlook
was so out of sync with his own time it
really anticipated elements of modernism
and postmodernism much more than it did
sort of his contemporary literary scene
so
moby dick for example is a very
unconventional kind of novel it's a mix
of genres it ostensibly starts off as
like a conventional whaling voyage but
then it becomes like this metaphysical
epic quest between of course captain
ahab and the white whale so
this really threw off readers and
writers or reviewers at the time
but it became much more impressive
within a 20th century context so
that's sometimes the context to which
bartleby is also sort of looked at in
terms of you know melville's own
frustrations as a struggling writer like
this misunderstood artist and the fact
that he wrote bartleby like just two
years after moby dick sometimes plays
into this sort of autobiographical
reading of melville the man and bartleby
the scrivener but um
that's just sort of a brief overview of
melville and kind of how he stood in
relation to his own peers at least in
the literary scene and did he work on
wall street because he always there's he
never gives the address of the place at
least in the version that i have
the address is blanked out so i wondered
if there was like something yeah
that that's a common literary convention
of like the 19th century like you see it
even in russian novels certain like
formal businesses and addresses are not
mentioned but yeah i don't think he's
actually protecting his own like former
employers or anything so we have the
19th century version of any relation to
actual people is entirely coincidental
don't sue us cool but uh it is based on
personal experience yeah
for sure yeah yeah
i wanted he was a new yorker yeah
i just want to add one thing because
it's kind of crucial to my own reading
uh this is kind of cicerone piece but
apparently his family started off very
very wealthy uh one of the wealthiest
families in new york uh but the dad had
serious debts and when he died it turned
out that there was nothing to the family
name
and so he kind of just made his way
initially living on the charity of his
various relatives before they eventually
kicked him out and said you got to go
make a living of your own and that's why
i ended up doing all these different odd
jobs
and i really like that actually because
he really almost was a character in a
19th century novel i mean it kind of
reminded me a bit of david copperfield
just learning a little bit about his own
biography right it's like oh it's a
wealthy family falls apart goes lives
amongst the cannibals writes type e
becomes a success then all this random
[ __ ] happens in artistic stuff i'm like
you couldn't you could write this stuff
but you'd have to be pretty talented to
come up with a story like melville's
life
and his family legacy actually lives on
so little known fact is that the minor
celebrity the electronic uh musician
moby is actually one of his descendants
so his great great great great nephew or
something
so
artistic talent apparently is genetic
right
yeah so that's being moby talented like
i said a minor celebrity of the 1990s
perhaps but um yeah
he got his stage name from the famous
movie yeah
that guy in those eminem songs
he can get stopped by obi
yeah better known from the eminem yeah
this
porcelain good songs from them from the
movie the beach with leonardo dicaprio i
feel like that that that moby album from
before is like fully featured in that
movie if any of you remember it good
soundtrack the only song of his i
remember is the one where he's like hey
that's the one what's the what's the
name of that again porcelain
okay yeah that's not a bad song
okay victor can you connect us to
i'm really into this idea that he was
out of sync with his time for whatever
reason and then became
you know like the american novelist
later on so can you connect that to
uh i guess the
germinating state of capitalism i mean
this happens on wall street but it's
before wall street was wall street which
is a
more than a happy accident of course but
how did his uh
position and the context lead from him
becoming a quack to
the great american novelist yeah so
perhaps because of his somewhat you know
david copperfield resume as matt noted
as well uh he had a somewhat pessimistic
vision at times of our ability to form
meaningful narratives in this
increasingly kind of industrialized
secularized world of the 1840s and 1850s
in in the u.s
and that's something that uh this was a
recurring interest for him he comes back
to this in a lot of his writing and
even before we kind of turn to bartleby
it's worth actually foregrounding the
opening of moby dick because there is an
interesting similarity there where
ishmael himself in the famous opening
passages where you know he starts with
call me ishmael and everything like that
specifically remarks how he feels
alienated and sort of like detached from
the nine to five kind of work grind that
he sees his peers having to participate
in in new york city
and that's actually what kind of makes
him look out to the sea and out to like
a different kind of existence and what
makes him ultimately join his the faded
whaling voyage but
he specifically got kind of like
comments at length on um how he's he he
doesn't understand how people can live
sort of like tied to counters nailed to
benches clinched to desks basically kind
of like as captives in the sort of
office space environment
which is what makes him then look to the
broader kind of global sort of like
stage that he could sort of live on so
already we see elements of bartleby the
scrivener's own dissatisfaction even in
moby dicks even in ishmael's own kind of
like um
restlessness in new york city
and i would say in relation to the
broader kind of cultural moment in the
u.s yeah
melville's kind of interest in this
restlessness i think highlights
attention maybe between
america's growth as an industrialized
economy during this time and
it's older kind of like frontier spirit
it's emphasis on individualism you know
self-reliance of making your own destiny
and kind of
not conforming to institutions and
there's this friction that you see start
to emerge between
that sort of american spirit and
experience
and the reality of having to become you
know like a basically
a human photocopier for the middle class
right for so many americans who had to
do what bartleby ends up having to do
right so that tension between sort of
your own you know
manifest destiny the frontier spirit as
an individual
and then the the reality of like having
to work as a copyist as a scrivener
that's something that melville kind of
recognized and put his pulse on and
something which of course only becomes
more relevant as we go into the 20th
century and you know
labor takes on even more forms of
significance
yeah i do want to say that i worked as a
secretary to a secretary at one point
for a couple months and my job was just
responding to people's complaints uh
usually via email sometimes be a lover
and there were parts of this that like
personally resonated with me where i was
just thinking like holy [ __ ] like the
number of times i thought like i'd
prefer not to do that but then of course
i did do it right it was just
unfathomable oh man if you've ever
worked in an office this is the most
relatable
essay
yeah short story you've ever read
um so i don't know if we have to do any
more i mean this is really fascinating
because he was kind of at the the
heartland this is pre-civil war right
also yeah yeah so it's kind of the
center of this new burgeoning uh
republican power in new york city
wall street and
i i find it so fascinating that it
wasn't recognized at the time did he die
in obscurity or anything like that or
did this book sell or did uh moby dick
sell by the end of his life
was like a catastrophic failure yeah oh
wow and melville
increasingly depressed he lived for
another couple of decades until the
1890s but
the critical re-evaluation of moby dick
did not begin until the 1920s and it was
actually the english press like in the
uk
who first took a renewed interest
because it was the sort of the
centennial of melville's birth
but during his own life he was very much
the unappreciated kind of struggling
artist yeah because this is this is
incredible that you have this like urban
professional class this is supposed to
be the land of opportunity but then it's
turning out to be you just sit and copy
other people's work all day nothing's
original nothing's expected of you to be
original so then there's this look to
the an old frontier actually like going
to whale and then there's this
mythologized
journey that happens in moby dick where
it's
uh yeah like you said it sets off as
this escape
from
um an entrapped cage of the urban
even the middle class at this point
i want to say that i do actually feel a
little bit bad for him because he seemed
to be cognizant of the fact that his
rece the reception of that book was
going to go south like his first novel
tp apparently was a huge success uh and
the person i was listening to was
talking about the book said what's not
to like you know it was based on actual
experience it was about landing on an
island with cannibals he ends up getting
a wife so you know there's sex violence
adventure
big gigantic hit and this is what people
just expected melville to keep churning
out you know these kind of ocean
adventure stories like robert louis
stevenson and then he's
he wrote a letter apparently to
nathaniel hawthorne saying
be it you know the public be damned i
know it's not going to sell a bit but i
have to express myself with this book uh
and he seemed cognizant of the fact that
it was going to be a flop and then it
was um
and it's kind of disappointing when your
low expectations of the public turn out
to be vindicated and nobody actually
wants to deal with like this big meaty
story they just want sex and violence
and cannibalism uh i guess because it's
tastier right absolutely yeah and it is
worth noting that melville seems to have
kind of revised his plans even for moby
dick like he started writing off the
more conventional kind of robert louis
stevenson you know maritime adventure
but then he also got caught up in kind
of the some of the literary currents of
the time including nathaniel hawthorne
as you mentioned but also walt whitman
kind of the american literary
renaissance of the 1850s and he had a
grander idea in mind he wanted to kind
of write you know the the existential
epic of the century so he definitely
kind of delivered something far more
unconventional
and the audience just wasn't ready for
it like the public was not sure what to
make of this strange novel again the
reception was somewhat warmer in england
ironically again
but in most of the us yeah this this
novel was a failure and then
eventually he had to kind of settle for
writing short stories like bartleby but
you could tell that even there of course
he's still kind of pushing back against
what's expected of him like he still is
very much a non-conformist as a writer
and sort of
a public figure yeah so i want to ask
you about my interpretation uh
of this because i'm sure the others are
going to give a fairly left-wing
interpretation of it which i think it's
i mean there's nothing wrong with
interpreting a tux like this in a
variety of different ways because i
think it lends itself essentially this
kind of archetypal quality right where
you read into it the expectations of
your era but one of the things that i
noted is that one of the only figures
that he refers to twice in the text is
cicero in particular the bust of cicero
which itself is telling
and cicero was this famously
aristocratic
member of the ultimate class in
republican rome who fought against oddly
enough the populist princip or sorry
populares of julius caesar and marc
anthony
insisting that you know the senate uh
needs to kind of push back against the
degradation of the people um and
eventually they lost and of course you
know the populist rose to power and
eventually we get the roman empire stuff
and cicero ends up getting killed right
but the way that i interpreted this was
he was kind of almost a modern cicero uh
he has this kind of aristocratic veneer
not quite necessarily working class
but almost above the kind of mediocrity
of the middle class that's insisting
that you engage in these banal tasks in
order to make money and elevate yourself
uh he has like higher aspirations and
interest than that would that be like a
wrong interpretation oh for sure yeah i
mean you you have to remember too that
everything we see about bartleby is from
the narrator's point of view right or
from the lawyer's point of view his boss
so
his boss doesn't understand him he can't
sort of classify him in any of the
conventional categories that would make
sense to him so of course
he tries to think of him as a vagrant as
somebody who's not doing his job you
know
a loafer but of course he can be seen as
somebody who has a much more noble kind
of like response to the work that he is
sort of being forced to do bartleby can
be seen as kind of like this song
he can seem to have an almost
aristocratic attachment a ciceronian
sense of like this work being beneath
him so
it's very notable that we don't sort of
see bartleby's own perspective or his
own thought process as the why is he
refusing why does he prefer not to do
what the lawyer boss expects of him
right
and that's what makes this i think what
has made it such a rich text for
critical readings because
there is no final answer we have to sort
of finish it ourselves we have to
interpret it on our own terms in terms
of like
why does bartle be
not conformed to the expectations
presented of him okay so since you've
brought up the
context of the story we might as well go
over the story um spoiler alert we're
gonna spoil it
but uh does anyone want to take that on
eric you haven't you haven't talked much
you want to summarize what happens for
us yeah i mean basically um the narrator
who is also the owner of this business
of
scrivenering um
yeah it's a it's
well it's a law firm but it seems like
they mostly specialize in
certain kinds of property and certain
kinds of like really boring out of the
way cases the guy said he's the the
owner is not one who to
do the sort of valiant
lawyering in front of a jury and like no
no romantic view of lawyers for this guy
he's just like a law firm slash copyist
firm
and what happens is um he gets appointed
to this mysterious office that i'm not
sure of called the chancery which to my
understanding uh dealt was the highest
court of appeal in the united states and
in many places until it got sort of
you know absorbed into the supreme court
but this new appointment that he
receives necessitates his hiring a new
scrivener to supplement his office for
the extra work they'll be getting he
already has three
very sort of colorful strange
characters uh working for him
and then his uh search for a new
employee leads him to receive this uh
bartleby as an applicant who he uh
promptly hires not realizing the extent
of the strangeness of this guy he just
seems like a kind of
laid back very morose not very uh
very lack of affect kind of guy and he
works day and night
and um i mean we already sort of went
over the rest of it you know this guy
bartleby
refuses he rep he refuses to do anything
except sit at his desk and work you know
and just copy and copy and copy but he
refuses so politely too he prefers not
to which is what's so frustrating about
it
it's also interesting that he does keep
doing his job at least at the beginning
right like nominally like he's just he's
doing the copying it's just like
initially i think like the boss is like
come come to come to this meeting in my
office where we can like go over the
copying to like look for errors or
something like that yeah and he's just
like i would prefer not to yeah there's
parts of a copy is job
this reminds me so much of like working
in an office and you have to do all this
team building [ __ ]
and you have to go to meetings that
don't actually involve you they just say
we'd like you to know what's going on
and the most relieving thing would be to
say i prefer not to and not have to go
but then of course your job's on the
line
yeah it reminded me almost one of those
morale building exercises that they do
where it's like listen you know your
company and the people at it really care
about you so come to us and share your
feelings uh and you know perfectly well
that because the power dynamics involved
you can't just [ __ ] say how you
really feel about it and what's kind of
sharply amazing about this is he does
say how he feels about it and his
argument is i don't want to go to these
[ __ ] morale building exercises where
i tell you what i feel i feel i prefer
not to right it's really refreshing in a
lot of ways
yeah and the and the setup of the of the
office is kind of significant as well
right like we've been talking about
cicero a bit there's a there's a bust of
cicero prominently on display in the
boss's office
really it's just one room that's divided
in two by glass doors
there's a sort of view of a brick wall
in like a sort of one of those internal
light shafts inside of buildings there's
a window that's viewing a brick wall and
then there's the other side of the
office not really much to look at i kind
of picture this office almost as like a
reprise of the inside of the whale it's
it's an enclosure and it's got a certain
kind of division
the boss has got his own half
which he ends up sticking um
bartleby in the corner of his half of
the office then his three
very odd
and irritable employees
are in the other half
and he calls them in to do the reading
of the copies of course and that's the
first thing that bartleby refuses to do
is check his work basically all he wants
to do is sit there day and night and
copy they they don't say that or he
doesn't say this explicitly but is is
turkey just a drunk because he says he
he comes in he's morose he's in a good
temper but then as the day goes on his
face gets redder he gets more animated
and angry
yeah there's something
about him drinking beer with
what they're oddly calling dinner which
seems to be lunchtime and
yeah so and then there's this weird swap
right where turkey
the first guy becomes very irritable and
excitable and crazy in the afternoon
whereas the other guy
nippers is this oh yeah can i just say
the name
of the morning there's street
names
they're supposed to they're nicknames
and they're supposed to express
something about their characters so
turkey is like a short squat out of
breath english guy
and nippers is always grinding his teeth
right and gingernut is the boy of the
office who goes out to get the gingernut
cakes and brings them back
so they all kind of like they're these
really sort of
flat almost like literary caricature
people who just have these sorts of very
prominent features but no real backstory
they're just they're they're very i
don't know they're they're satirical
they're just like pure personalities
with a couple traits and it's worth
noting too like contrasting them with
bart will be how predictable they are
right like one guy is reliably more
productive in the morning the other one
swaps with him and he's more productive
in the afternoon
and so this is like almost there's a
reliability to them which then
completely goes out the window with
bartleby that's what kind of sets up the
punch line with i would prefer does he
even try like at the beginning am i am i
misremembering or does the boss also
like talk about like how the nicknames
and how he's trying to think of one for
bartleby how he'll like eventually
develop one but never does or is that is
that is that my imagination i don't
recall them thinking of a nickname for
bartleby and they just kind of refer to
him well he doesn't i know he doesn't
but i thought like he did there's a i
thought there's like an ant where he
talks about like why how he thinks about
the other employees and exactly like
predictably he like talks about how like
oh like whatever turkey does this and
he's pre and it's like just like victor
was saying like the predictability but i
thought he also said something like you
know eventually i'll get
a name once i understand this new
employee bart will be like he'll get one
but he never does right he's never ever
does exactly and it's it's it's worth
noting how he does describe bartle
because it's an increasingly like kind
of uncanny terms like oh this apparition
this this incubus who haunts the office
right like he's really unsettled by the
fact that he can't give him a nickname
in a way that he can't really assert his
authority in the office with him
yeah he's very supportive
yeah
i want to say that like i did
i think uh eric what eric said is uh
what you said victor uh is really
telling right because there is almost
the stakansi quality to the three
central characters like when i heard the
name turkey and nut it really reminded
me of like oh fezzy wig or mr murdstone
where the minute you hear the name you
think oh this is who this person is
going to be in the story and dickens had
a real knack for that but like barbie
almost kind of
is insulated uh from this attempt to
kind of classify him under the label of
any of these kind of cliches or
expectations right
but like even more than that right um
it's the fact that
he deliberately provokes the characters
around him into acting in ways that are
counter to their own initial
inclinations so there's almost this
expectation that because you have these
characters at the outset that are
supposed to behave this way you know
what's going to happen and then his
presence prevents them from acting in
the scripted way which is a big reason
why it is that they all react so
fiercely to him oh and by the way pills
uh there is a point where they do
reference that turkey is a drunk uh it's
when his boss tries to get him a coat
and he says the problem with turkey is
that a man who likes to drink like he
does can also afford a nice coat so in
the contest between the coat and the
drink
the drink always wins and then he goes
on to say i just bought him him a coat
one day and it didn't make any
difference because it came in and he was
greasy and smelly anyway which i thought
was pretty amazing
yeah
yeah they're really insubordinate but he
finds a way to sort of work with them
right like turkey's really productive in
the morning so he gives them all this
work to do in the morning but then he
sort of spills ink everywhere and
is really clumsy and
turns to this red-faced drunk guy in the
afternoon so he's like okay just give
him like sort of busy work to do and
then this other guys who
kind of i don't know nippers is a bit of
a strange dude right he never sleeps
well so he always comes in like he's
woken up on the wrong side of the bed
he's pissy he'll the boss will glance
out and see him like fighting with his
desk like he's almost like an a precise
engineer trying to just get his desk
just right it's too high it makes his it
it makes his arms lose their circulation
right oh it's too low he has to hunch
over it makes his back hurt he's putting
little pieces of paper under his desk to
get it just right and then he'll look
back a few minutes later and nippers
will be like wrestling with his desk
like it's got a mind of its own it's
yeah when he says like i send ginger not
out to get those cakes but then turkey
is [ __ ] drunk and fat so he just eats
like six of them all in a go and i have
to send him out to get more right like
it's really it's great stuff and they're
so funny
the boss kind of just accepts that
low-key alcoholism or insomnia is just
part of the job like it says so much
about the workspace about the kind of
work that these people have to do yeah
also it's it it says something about
like the manager like his managerial
philosophy he's just like okay like i'm
gonna like my almost like he's like my
job is to like i have these people and
i'm gonna like work with them and i'll
find a way it's just but i need to
understand them first i need to see
their patterns and then i'll be able to
like plug them in and then this will be
the solution he has that and then you
can tell as the narrative goes on when
he tries to solve bartleby and he just
can't you know typical office
environment we got all our characters i
just want to finish sort of the synopsis
here
he increasingly
gets frustrated but
not specifically mad at bartleby because
whenever he asks bartleby to do anything
he says can you go pick something up
from the post office i would prefer not
to can you come go over these edits with
me i would prefer not to and then he
just asks him the most basic thing can
you go get the guy from the other room
and tell him to come here i would prefer
not to
barkley where are you from
i would prefer not to speak on that at
this time so he just refuses to work
with this guy at all we only get the
bosses in her monologue and he
brings in all this uh like christian
morality sort of language and says
this was this is one of the most
miserable pitiable creatures i've ever
seen i knew i couldn't fire him because
if i
fired him then a worse boss would not
treat him as well as i'm treating him so
it's almost um we know that it's written
in the past tense it's almost justifying
that he did everything he could for this
guy the guy just wouldn't obey wouldn't
serve
and then we find out by the end of the
story bartleby eventually refuses to
work
so the boss moves his entire law firm to
a different building and just leaves
bartleby standing in the middle of the
room by himself
he refused to leave too even he stops
paying him he gives him like a severance
package bonus and bartleby refuses to
leave he just wants to stand in the
office like this guy's sleeping in the
office so then the building
living
quickly then the building manager tries
to re-rent out the office bartleby is
still standing in there
long story short bartleby ends up in
prison not having
committed an actual crime they never
charge him with anything but he won't
move so he ends up in prison
there they start trying to feed him he
says i don't like eating dinner i prefer
not to eat dinner and eventually he
starves to death
in prison and that's the end of the
story and then there's a weird uh
a weird appendix at the end but i'm not
sure how to interpret that but anyway
victor i wanted you to uh catch us up on
how how we go about literary
interpretation of this whole
almost increasingly absurd story
no that's the thing yeah it gets almost
kafka-esque right and in our little
dickensian you know 19th century short
story
once bartleby shows up the other
characters have no clue how to deal with
him because he really is like from
another century from another genre they
just like look at each other and they
shrug like why aren't you sort of
conforming to the script why aren't you
one of the office
employees right he just doesn't want to
he starts to infect the others too
interestingly right they all start to
use this word prefer without with say
they say prefer to this prefer that
would you prefer i've never used the
word prefer before but i find myself
slowly using it
doesn't even notice i think there's a
really important point though this erner
makes about himself relative to bartleby
at the very beginning uh which kind of
explains why these characters are there
and why he tolerates them but also like
his relationship to bartleby which is he
says i'm a guy who always wants things
to be easy right i always am the person
who thinks that the easiest path is the
one that you should take right and
what's kind of paradoxical about him is
despite the fact that his that's his
philosophy he's the one who does almost
all the work in the short story right he
ends up moving offices hauling ass
somewhere else it's just desperately
trying to play kate bartleby and
bartleby despite the fact that he
doesn't adopt this kind of philosophy of
taking it easy if anything he's
extremely hard on himself near the end
he's the one who actually does actually
absolutely nothing
at the finale of it right he just stands
there like bills was saying then lets
himself get straight to prison and then
dies
so there's this really interesting
juxtaposition between a man who wants to
take things easy and winds up turning
his whole life around because of
somebody who just will do nothing but
stand in one place and looking out and
look at a wall right yeah and to your
point pills so at the literary level
like bartleby's almost like an
anti-character right like he kind of
blows up the story because this is some
you know you're expecting a more typical
kind of office space comedic kind of
short story
and then this existential character
shows up again who clearly is not like
really at home in the 19th century at
this point in terms of what american
readers were expecting
and he just completely throws the story
upside down and so that's what's really
interesting here is that you know you
can almost see what how melville's
readers would have reacted to a story
like this or even to like moby dick like
we were talking about earlier there they
would be like as confused as the bosses
as to like why are you subverting the
expectations why are you not playing
along with the system right whether it's
like
genre expectations or like economic
expectations
he's like you know that's what's so
interesting here that this is working at
many different levels
yeah it made me think like if a terence
mallet character just happened to step
into like the office or something and
like michael scott was just like how the
[ __ ] am i supposed to deal with you and
he just kept on saying these very soft
epigrams but then there's a voice over
where there's all these profound
thoughts flowing right it's just this
person doesn't belong in the genre but i
think that's kind of where a lot of the
comedy comes out right yeah and
scriveners are an odd bunch as the uh
narrator sort of relates but he wants to
focus on this one he's he wants to tell
this story of bartleby even though he
doesn't know anything about him because
bartleby wouldn't say anything ever you
can't ask him who he is where he's from
if he has any relatives
nothing it's this this
unicorn [ __ ] character
who we just get a few snippets of
his
last bit of his life
it's also interesting
about the way that the boss kind of
tells himself
like his rationalizations so like for me
there's a bit of ambiguity about
what it meant because pills was saying
like there's all this christian morality
there and like i mean i like it's true
that came across but like i don't know
like like my thought when i was reading
it was more that
he's such a coward uh or something that
like that like he's just making up these
rationalizations for like what a good
person he is when really he's just like
a non-confrontational coward
who like who like doesn't know how to
how to like
how to just like say like get the [ __ ]
out of here and like exert some force
because he's always been able to
finagle his employees to do what he
wants with these kinds of like generous
nice things but is really
non-confrontational
so i didn't i didn't see the main
motivation as being christian morality i
saw it as just like the boss's own
psychological cowardice well he's
fascinated by him right he's fascinated
and repelled by this character and then
he and then the rationalizations too he
like talks about how he's like oh what a
poor soul like it's like i'm gonna help
them i'm gonna do these things and to me
i'm just like you're just lying to
yourself because you're just too scared
to just like do what's necessary well
like any normal boss would just be like
set this guy out on his ass immediately
obviously but he kind of like you know
the delay of the what do you call it the
uh
the delay of the desire of this story is
that he's trying to indulge this guy
sure i'd like christian grounds but
really
that's just a justification for it
bartleby is completely disarming
in his sort of you know if there's a
hint of of combativeness in his
utterances of this phrase over and over
i'd prefer not to then you know the boss
would say ah there's the spark of
humanity i'm gonna [ __ ] this guy up but
bartleby is almost like an automaton
with no affect whatsoever just complete
like placid is a lake his emotions are
just like all
flat nothing it is and it is interesting
like that in thinking about like um
non-confrontational kind of and like
avoiding pure confrontation i mean
clearly like bartleby's like form of
resistance is also very
non-confrontational right so it's like
you have two non-confrontational
characters like like so it's because
bartleby's just like i would prefer not
to he never just says directly no
um
and then like the boss also just like is
is flummoxed and and is
dealing with it in very
non-confrontational manners so it's like
so it's like neither of them actually
says like kind of what
what i mean i mean bartleby's clear
right he's like i would prefer not to
but but he's doing it in a very like the
least confrontational way of saying no
possible and that's like jesus shirt's
interpretation of the story right is
it's the great refusal it's what we need
to do to capitalism
is just saying confirming the negative
the boss describes several times i mean
bartleby is living in this guy's head
rent free like every day the boss is
trying to work but he's focused on
bartleby
and then he describes how much power
bartleby has over him
even just like he shows up to the office
on a sunday no one's supposed to be in
the office he's gonna go like pick up
some work
bartleby's in there just like sleeping
or changing or something and he goes uh
i'm not done yet go walk around the
block a few times and the guy does it
and then describes to us the reader i
don't i don't know why i did that i just
felt like there was nothing else i could
do because he'd never been uh challenged
before no and it's great to see how this
really undermines his authority over his
own workspace right over like his firm
there because by the end of it he's
almost like convincing himself that like
no this this must be like have been
predestined by god this is my struggle
to bear like he's trying to justify it
like he's searching for meaning as to
why he has to deal with bartleby all
because like he senses like the limits
of coercion with someone like this right
like he is actually sort of like his
life begins to revolve around bartleby
bartleby is just there right he's not
really doing anything but yeah the
questions of agency are so interesting
here as to like who's really free and
who isn't yeah but that's what's gonna
get it i don't really think that the
landlord if you want uh reflects like a
genuine kind of christian morality i
think that pills is absolutely right
that it's a kind of satire of christian
morality because it's really like a kind
of white middle class christian morality
right where almost everything that he's
doing is about his own
self-gratification uh or trying to
placate his uneasy conscience uh because
one of the things that's distinctive
about this
yeah this story is that he never really
makes a sincere effort to try to
understand bartleby the way that
bartleby might understand him he's not
interested in his own internal life his
own soul if you want all that he tends
to think about is this would be a nice
thing to do for him or he wants the same
things that i do so i just need to find
the lever
and i'll get him to move right uh and
in many ways there's this kind of almost
proto-nichian satire uh of all the
different ways that he tries to construe
this indifference to his inner life uh
as some kind of moral act on the boss's
part uh when really it all services this
kind of narcissistic yearning for
acceptance
and for gratification from somebody who
makes it really clear from the get-go
that he's not going to give it to that
guy right he has no interest he prefers
not to give him any of that kind of
recognition or consolation
michael scott popped into my head more
than more than a few times reading this
like he wants to be friends with anybody
everybody but he cannot stand that this
guy does not like him does not want to
be friends with him wants nothing from
him and then doesn't like accept his
his his generosity as a as a boss yeah
and that's why people don't really like
michael scott a lot of the times right
because most of the nice things that he
does for people are kind of foe and he
doesn't really pay that much attention
to his employees his people he just kind
of does what he thinks that they want uh
whereas bartleby makes it like
emphatically clear what he doesn't want
at least he kind of wants to be left
alone and he prefer not to do any of the
[ __ ] that he's told to do
and that's the one thing he can't wrap
his head around right so victor can you
help us out with the
the dominant reading of this story now
is a class analysis it's we got the boss
we got the lower class the lower class
not understood
the boss
you know making every effort to be
friendly but still doesn't understand
authority being subverted in this way
are there other readings of this or is
that kind of what you think melville was
going for yeah i mean there's so many
ways to approach this text you could
look at it again as like the writer
being misunderstood by society at the
most basic kind of autobiographical
level
everything from that to even you know
like disabled readings queer readings
right like okay the worker who does not
receive the accommodation he needs
or even we could like turn it on its
head okay the conservative point of view
a cautionary tale about welfare system
abuse like
there's really something here for
everyone there's i was actually reminded
of a simpsons moment where um ned
flanders is asked by one of his sons
like why do we pay taxes and he says
well you know it's partly for the people
who just don't want to work god bless
him
and that's kind of yeah i mean maybe
that's bartleby's situation by the end
he's just he wants to be in it but not
of it he's just part of society but not
really in the way that society needs him
to be so
we could be critical of bartleby too
there's we could take the side of the
narrator why not yeah i wonder if this
this sort of image at the end we get
think about the thing about the
capitalist what about him he had to move
his whole office what turned his whole
life upside down i mean the poor man
right he tried everything
you see that like part in the end right
where
bartleby's in prison i don't know if
this is
the like sort of origin of this image
you know you picture like um
1984 right this like this sort of
horrible totalitarian world but somehow
you know like a blade of grass blooms
through all the heavy the heavy like
machinery right and like love sort of
finds a way and in the end of this story
too like you know bartleby's there in
prison and then he writes
you know comparing this prison to like
an egyptian pyramid where people are
just entombed he says in the heart of
this pyramid here
where by some strange magic through the
cleft's grass seed dropped by birds had
sprung there's little there's this sort
of were left this image of grass growing
through the like cracks in the prison
floor
and it's it's a really strange
sort of image
i don't know what it is it's supposed to
be i i guess it's been interpreted in an
almost
you know what going to like beyonce
reading of or actually this is a
gambin's reading gives it a kind of
a messianic
interpretation right the sky and the
blades of grass and it's like
i don't know bartleby almost as like a
messiah you know chilhan will completely
disagree with this reading but you know
these weird sorts of moments
i guess they they recommend that reading
in a way
can i ask you a different question
victor because this is kind of that the
this is one of the problems i've always
had with melville
and i've never been able to wrap my head
around it so maybe you'll have the
answer right because i've seen a lot of
different readings of moby dick which
i'm more familiar with which try to
really insist uh that the story is an
allegory you know and they'll say
ishmael is ishmael from the bible the
whale is god ahab is you know insert
your favorite thing lucifer you know is
one i've seen a lot you know uh and
you could do something similar to this
which is to try to read into this like
oh you know the boss represents
capitalism bridal b represents the
oppressed workers that's the allegory of
the story right but it seems to me that
this is a story
kind of like my interpretation of moby
dick that
almost distances itself from the
possibility of being read allegorically
it almost seems to invite
archetypal kinds of readings where
you're going to deliberately read into
it what it is that you want to see
because there's so many different ways
that this was deliberately intended to
be construed absolutely yeah i mean i
think at some level as long as we're
trying to sort of pin bartleby down and
interpret it in one way we're still kind
of doing what his boss is doing right
we're trying to give him like a nickname
but in some ways yeah you're right maybe
melville is actually inviting us to kind
of go beyond that level and to recognize
like there's something deeply
ungraspable here and that's fine like
you have to be okay with that kind of
ambiguity and he does sort of yeah it's
so hyper allegorical in some ways he's
almost like tossing out so many little
references you know cicero egypt
everything that yeah i think that in
some ways yeah you could sort of compare
to moby dick where ultimately like
you don't want to kind of fall into like
ahab's position and try to like figure
out what does the white whale mean what
does bartleby mean like it's more about
the process of interpretation itself
that perhaps melville is kind of trying
to steer us towards is to actually like
it's it's it's a meditation on critical
reading right
and more more so than the actual sort of
like destination of like the definitive
take
on this character or anything like that
yeah yeah i think that's right because
the the narrator really projects like
the possibility of his own salvation on
to bartleby right like bartleby's a
blank slate he's uh he's a he's a blank
piece of paper
and the narrator
you know in the end oddly like a spoiler
alert when bartleby
sort of dies in the end right he just
kind of stops living and
and he touches him and he feels that
he's cold
and then when the the grub man of the
prison asks you know dinner's ready is
he coming and he said uh he's sleeping
uh oh he's asleep and then the narrator
ends the sort of main part of the story
ends with him saying he's sleeping with
kings and counselors the sort of odd
wistful moment that the narrator ends on
like bartleby becomes almost like a prop
in in the narrator's own internal epic
rather than
yeah and rather than a substantial
character so i kind of get that reading
where bartleby resists
interpretation so we just kind of
violently appropriate him for our own
sort of thoughts right but then there's
this weird epilogue and in this weird
epilogue the narrator finds out that
uh bartleby came from the dead letter
office
and dead letters are like dead men so he
he kind of
um exhumes his conscience at the end of
the story saying there was something
wrong with this guy before i got him i
didn't [ __ ] him up he was [ __ ] up
before he got here
and it's gonna be like until the early
20th century like 60 years after this
was written that we get the internal
monologues of character like bartleby
in kamu or kafka where you get what
bartleby's actually thinking but until
then it's kind of just projection from
the outside because i'm just going to
give full disclosure right like i was
i've been so used to the left-wing
reading of this that i immediately went
into it thinking that that's what i was
going to see right like i was going to
see
basically a proto marxist bar to be you
know
carrying the red flag before the red
flag even existed right and i i like
that reading i think there's nothing
wrong with it but like i said the way
that i came away from it was almost the
exact opposite reading where i saw him
as almost a kind of nostalgic
reactionary figure you know a man
outside of modernity who resists his
vulgarity and has this kind of nobility
to him uh that resists being reduced to
the level of the mass uh and refuses to
abide by that right which is not which
is a very different reading than that
one right but now i'm kind of wondering
if that's just also me
reading too much into the cicero
comments kind of like victor was saying
you know seeing those as the clues to
answer the riddle of what this is about
and imposing my own kind of answer into
like bartleby equals you know the modern
cicero or something all right
i've had this entire nichian monologue
going all the time like this [ __ ]
[ __ ] is telling me to do stuff i'm
just gonna say no
it's hard to believe that there's
anything going on in there
he seemed just kind of dead inside
no it's it's hard it's hard to believe
that there hasn't been a follow-up from
like bartleby's point of view right like
the the the untold story and it is
something like comically nietzschean or
something
yeah yeah no i mean i i i also think
like the the one of the things about the
left-wing reading i mean
because i came into it hearing i mean
i'd read what philosophers like zizek
um had said about it but i hadn't
actually read the the short story myself
and
you know reading it like coming away
from it i i guess i do i do see like the
left-wing potential i suppose but i also
i don't know but to me it's like well he
just like dies at the end and he just i
mean he just seems like a like a like a
madman like he doesn't see he died a
hero victor he died of heroes
i don't know but it and it's i don't
know it just doesn't it doesn't that
that reading doesn't seem as clear-cut
to me after actually reading the source
material all right let me go into these
i don't know if you guys if you have
just interrupt me if you have any uh
points but the left ring reading that
we're referencing generally is sort of
shared by
a gambin heart negri and zizek
and
deluz and byung chul han have a
different reading against
those that left-wing reading but it's
generally if you're in a system
where you if you're saying no
to the system then you're basically
accepting its authority but this is
revolutionary because not only is he
just not saying
no but he's affirming
a negation saying i prefer not to he's
not saying no i won't but just i prefer
not to meaning he's not giving any
assent to the system you can force me to
go to the prison i prefer not to you can
force me to work i prefer not to and by
that mechanism i think which is accurate
to the story he takes away all of the
boss's power the boss has no idea what
to do with him and
in terms of agency in the story bartleby
ends up becoming the most agentic
character like after he moves his office
basically a mob comes over and says
yo you [ __ ] left this dude in our
apartment building you have to get rid
of him and he goes well
why do i have to get rid of him i don't
know him he was just a former employee
but he causes such a big stir about
around the city and around the system
by not doing
anything yeah yeah absolutely right i
mean yeah speaking of christian
characters you know there we go you can
interpret it maybe not as the modern
christian like cicero but the modern
christ you know what i mean a man too
good for this world because he refused
to work and shown a light of shame upon
the rest of us or something all right
well here's here's a one quote from
jijek's parallax view
he says bartleby symbolizes sort of the
pass
from the politics of resistance or
protestation which parasitizes upon that
which it negates
to a politics which opens up a new space
outside of the hegemonic position and
its negation so he just passes beyond
negation into a totally new space victor
do woody how do you feel about that
reading
well i was wait which way
i met you because you said you don't buy
this i didn't say i don't buy it it just
didn't seem as clear to me anyway i mean
i i think that he's
um you know this like but there's also
no content to bartleby that we can see
so it's like so so it's like yeah sure
he's like affirming a negation but it's
like for what like like there's nothing
there's no content he's just standing in
an office till like until people remove
him and then he just like decides not to
eat there's nothing there's nothing it's
just it's just a pure negation yeah it's
a sort of master slave kind of like boss
worker interpretation where it's like
you know
han goes for the more like psychological
interpretation so he disagrees but like
agon for instance kind of reads it along
the same line right he elevates bartleby
into this sort of metaphysical onto
theological character right and he said
like so goblin makes these grand
pronouncements which you'd be probably
hard-pressed to find evidence for in the
text except for
giving a gambin the creative room to say
this is the philosophical constellation
to which bart'll be the scrivener
belongs is a scribe who has stopped
writing bartleby is the extreme figure
of the nothing from which all creation
derives and at the same time he
constitutes the most implicable
vindication of this nothing as pure
absolute potentiality scrivener become
the writing tablet he is now nothing
other than his white sheep right so this
this idea of
this negative act signals the infinite
potentiality
is this reading that
you know the the kind of hegelian master
slave reading of the sort of absolute
negativity of the act of refusal
and and you know bill chilhandis doesn't
have that you know he says
like beyonce hans reading
is more you know
bartleby is a product of a disciplinary
society right because what melville's
describing is a disciplinary society
there's walls there's dividers there's
interiors there's prisons yeah there's
there's references to internment in
turing in in death tombs and things like
that right
and bartleby actually has this condition
we'd probably describe today as
neurasthenia
where he's just completely dead and flat
flat affect right he's got nothing going
on in there and he's just this sort of
you know reading
reading it into
his book called the burnout society
right well
in melville's day it hasn't reached this
sort of be all you can be
excess right this achievement society we
live in right like the nike just do it
society they're still in the
disciplinary society of the 19th century
so bartleby is a kind of product of that
milia where he manifests this complete
refusal
to do anything even eat and feed himself
and you know it's a very kind of
deflationary reading when you read it up
against the sorts of meanings that agon
and g-jek want to put into it but i
don't know about the other ones
who who else interprets this
can i just summarize these three
positions just in case anyone's not on
track so a gambin
for a gambin this is the site of pure
potentiality because bartleby has
escaped the dialectic he refuses to be a
master refuses to be a slave he just
opts out
for beyonce han he's the figure of
burnout condemned to a bureaucracy well
all he does is copy other people's
work with no relief
the pre-burnout burnout
he's like uh he's like the the
disciplinary society's like ultimate
products ultimate positivity no no drive
no apathy crushed spirit
then the third reading is jijax and
zizek is saying this is a correct
response to you know modern capitalism
today which is the self-help you've got
to go to the gym you got to do this you
got to be an ethical consumer you got to
pay attention to politics everywhere and
i would prefer not to is kind of the
correct escape from that
so the thing is i i resist that a little
bit because even though i think again it
can be which one do you resist kind of
the ethos underpinning all of them which
is to kind of interpret them as a
radical or insurrectionary figure and
the reason is that
first off like eric said i don't think
there's a lot of textual evidence to
support that but beyond that dude last
week you were fine with violent readings
when it was zuziac
putting words into de la's mouth but now
that it's philosophers putting words
into a blank character's mouth now
you're gonna take offense to textual
evidence sure sure i have no problem
with that and but i think again if you
interpret him it's very hard for me to
read him as a kind of heroic figure
right uh
it seems to me that he's leading a kind
of petty bourgeois life his boss makes
it pretty clear that he's not exactly
going to go hard on his employees right
that they can eat cakes and drink and
have a good time and do whatever it is
they want in the office as long as
they're relatively productive
and he himself ends up dying and there's
not even a sense that there's this kind
of
either christian or buddhist quality to
his passing away and the sense of either
escaping suffering or vindicating
suffering through his death as a kind of
grace he's just gone right and it would
seem to me that if melville was trying
to convey this kind of insurrectionary
quality to him something like that would
be suggested in the text right and i
have no problem with you know i put it a
violent reading of this
but the reason why i resisted is also it
seems to me that if we were to interpret
the inner monologue of somebody like
bridal bee it wouldn't be as an
insurrectionary figure that what kept on
coming to mind when i thought about it
was something more like dostoyevsky's
underground man right who refuses but
does so out of almost spite in a certain
sense right that he's going to cancel
the dialectic of existence by just
negating even his own desires uh for
existence
and doing something that's so contrarian
that even if it hurts him uh it's still
kind of free act right has this free
quality and that's not that's not
intended as a compromise i have a
textual evidence against that at least
from the narrator's point of view of
course but he said nothing was so
aggravating to me as an earnest person
in passive resistance poor fellow i
thought he means no mischief it is plain
he intends no insolence his aspect
sufficiently convinces me
that it's his in eccentricities okay
yeah so maybe it
lacks that quality but well that's that
but that's interesting because that to
me like i remember when i read that i
was like oh like he just wants to avoid
confrontation so he's just telling
himself this story
that it's like oh he's not actually like
doing anything malicious like he's just
that's just his weird peculiarity
because it's like it's
it's allowing him to defer
responsibility to actually have to
respond in a confrontational manner
that's how i read it
when the narrator does visit him in the
prison at the end though he can tell
it's clear that bartleby blames him that
he ended up in prison
yeah he had some responsibility towards
him it seems yeah no i i really like
these readings like agons that like you
know bartleby is actually new in the
matrix or something and he just like
at the end of the first movie he says no
and he just stops the bullets
from making spit i think that's that
says a lot more about like agon's
reading than it does about melville's
story but no i think that g-jack is
probably closest to like maybe the
spirit of the story where
i mean he compares bartleby's i prefer
not to with the like protest politics of
occupy wall street where okay like it's
great to clear the table kind of but you
have to offer a viable alternative
afterward right
and so that's the problem with bartleby
ends up just dying right like he negates
himself out of existence so if we're
going to read this politically i think
it's an interesting first step
but i think zijk would suggest it's not
enough i prefer not to
and then you know like there has to be
something more to this yeah that's what
i know about the underground kind of
reading right which is that this guy
also has a kind of radical
antagonism towards modernity but his
primary target at the end of the day is
always himself right and it's hard for
me not to look at this and say
i admire the fact that he did
dissociate from the system but it seems
like the main outcome of this is that he
ends up dying and suffering at the end
that's hard for me to interpret this as
a kind of heroic act that
presents it as an insurrectionary figure
the way some of these people seem to
want right yeah no that's exactly how i
felt about like feeling like yeah it's
interesting but there's like no content
it's just like there's like an emptiness
to it it's just i mean it's true it does
map on anybody maybe melville preferred
not to give content to this yeah yeah
sure sure but i mean it does i go i hear
what victor's saying because like i
think that that that that zizek
like i'm sympathetic to that because
that like you know it is this idea like
you guys know for long time listeners
like you'll know that i that i have my
gripes about just like edgy protest
politics that just gets caught up in
fact like my dissertation work to some
extent it's just like about
like you know just just protest politics
that gets caught up in just like being
against anything positive just being
like like you know trying to negate
institutions negate like like political
order for something else for this vague
notion of like whatever um
and i think like maybe that that fits in
with
those other kinds of readings that want
to see bartleby as a heroic a heroic
figure it fits in with that inclination
towards
more like um yeah i don't know edge
lordy politics i think in terms of a
textual correlate the closest thing i
can think of is kafka's hunger artist
yeah because the hunger artist doesn't
he starves himself to death spoiler
alert he starves himself to death for no
reason except that he never found any
food that he liked so he ends up in a
cage in the middle of town and he's
doing he's like a circus act where he
just doesn't eat and then people come by
and go oh look there's the hunger artist
not eating but we find out that the
reason that he didn't eat and starved
himself to death was that he didn't like
anything i think kafka's metamorphosis
is also like a great parallel where
again this character who is just
completely misunderstood by society they
don't know what to do with him he's so
grotesque in the fact that he no longer
works and eventually he also dies from
starvation right and that's a much more
extreme absurdist example but i i do
think that's an interesting parallel
yeah this is so kafka-esque it's
interesting that starvation plays a role
uh in all three of these characters also
again
as a kind of self-implosion uh rather
than an external act of violence that's
inflicted upon you right yeah and not
just starvation but hunger because
hunger is also the reason that ishmael
left his urban environment to go on the
whaling voyage
hunger here and starvation here is seen
not just as the effect of modernity but
the condition of modernity and hunger
for what
well we don't know that hunger for
anything but this
yeah but i mean i have to say because i
think we're i know we said that we had
to end up soon i really enjoyed this
right i enjoyed the conversation i
learned a lot and it kind of reminded me
of a lot of what great literature is
supposed to do in the sense that i've
been thinking of very little else aside
from this story uh
and lucerto over the last you know two
days um and for a 30 page story that's
quite an accomplishment right yeah no i
also uh very much enjoyed the story and
i was going to say before like when we
were talking about how bartleby affirms
nothing like it i mean people have made
the parallel with you know the the 19 i
think like 1998 movie you know office
space with that guy
and there is a scene when when the main
character right in that in that movie
he he obviously has that weird i mean
they're not the same stories at all but
i think maybe there's some inspiration
office space to uh from to the bartleby
story at least there's some parallels
but but it's just i'm reminded of when
peter gibbons like the main character
just stops going to work and stops
listening to his boss and
i guess there is the one parallel too
where peter gibbons's boss is also
extremely non-confrontational
ryan is like doing everything he can to
like avoid confrontation that's why he
always says
uh he always like says like yeah if you
could just go ahead and do this and he's
like saying yeah when he's actually
saying no right it's like this kind of
like non-confrontational yang
um but but there's a scene when peter
gibbons is like talking to like his love
interest jennifer aniston she's like
well what are you like you're just gonna
not go to work like what are you gonna
do and he's like nothing he's like i
would just want to sit on my ass and do
nothing and it's just like this
affirmation of just like nothing and
like that's really what he wants his
agenda really is to do nothing um and
it's just reminding me when we're
talking about like that bartleby's kind
of affirming
nothing you forgot the most important
part of that movie uh which is the
ghetto boys classic song damn it feels
good to be a gangster which accompanies
the montage of his doing nothing it's a
[ __ ] classic song it deserves more
respect uh than it got and if you're
listening ghetto boys because you happen
to like classic pills
shout out to you great song deserves
more respect than it gets send me a
message dm me whatever happens to be
let's get it back on traction
i think the the razor's edge we've kind
of talked touched around it a few times
but is
first of all is the narrator reliable
because if we take if we take his point
of view
bartleby's treated very well like no one
arresting him is a very last resort
people try to understand him
and i i guess if it falls on your
interpretation whether or not you he was
treated well whether or not you trust
the narrator that he was treated well
but that kind of diffuses this uh
radical political protest to a degree
unless you think that bartleby is the
kind of person who just protests against
the entire system and this is like his
artistic act is to let himself die at
the hands of the system by forcing it to
kill him
what reasons do we have what reasons do
we ever thinking that he's an unreliable
narrative is there like is there is
there evidence of that in the text
i mean i'm no literary like that's not
my feeling even the fact that he's
writing like after bartleby has already
died right like he knows how this ends
that already can make us a little
suspicious of okay you know what is he
trying to prove here who is he trying to
convince i was so nice to the fact that
this day i asked him about his family
i didn't like him so removed from
bartleby's own thought processes we have
to be a little bit skeptical when he we
see him project so much onto this
character yeah yeah a lot of the
characters in them in the story i was
almost called the novel remind me of
what like de tocqueville said about uh
the democratic spirit in america at the
time uh which is that it's kind of
compassionate and it's motivated by
sentiment but it's very superficial and
soft sentiment right it's not really
interested in probing into the
individuality or particularity of people
it's universalized in the kind of banal
sense of i care for everybody and i want
everyone to like me right and that
struck me as this narrator
chewity
as kind of exemplar of this democratic
ethos uh focus on ease
tranquility and taking the quickest past
and yearning for people to like him
right but i never thought the sense he
really cared about understanding
bartleby as a
yeah we're confined to the narrator's
point of view and it's told out of
memory obviously so yeah that's the
that's the probably the extent of the
unreliability
but interestingly whenever given a name
the narrator is never named but we know
things about him whereas bartleby is
named he doesn't know anything about him
yeah oh wait what are we talking about
no bartleby is named but the narrator
never is we don't know who the narrator
we don't know his name really so that
kind of invites some interesting
examples but
you know bu buncho han's reading is just
this is just a tale of exhaustion that's
what it is he's a product of
a disciplinary society
you know this the soul-crushing work of
scrivenering is in a way sort of
representative of these new sorts of
like one-dimensional men
as uh
as uh
they'd be called maybe in the mid 20th
century the this one-dimensional man
bartleby who is who's who is there you
know he he says in the prison he says i
know where i am you know when the when
the uh when the narrator kind of
recounts him coming himself coming in
and trying to be like oh well you're
gonna be you know treated well here and
you have all your own space and you're
fed and then and then bartleby kind of
just says i know where i am like he
knows he's he knows what's happening
but he just has no desire to stop it no
drive
no ambition he's completely apathetic
and that's that's it i don't think i
don't think there's any necessity to
read
into this some kind of messianic
you know second coming decreation so
that the second creation can take place
and bartleby's the messenger of this
like all that just seems like such
an unnecessary interpretive apparatus
built up around wishful thinking and
with a dash of marxist
hopefulness which is not bad but i mean
you know it's not what the story is
conveying the story is just cheer
you know
hopelessness that's what it is there's
no hope here and the the narrator at
least he can save himself he can save
his own soul if he can't save bartleby's
but he's never gonna escape that guilt
that he could have done something but he
didn't yeah like there's that really
funny sequence at the end in the prison
where he's giving him like a list of
different jobs he can do and he's like
what about being a bartender he's like i
think i prefer not to do that even
though i'm not particularly particular
especially in particular and there's
like well what about you know would you
like to work for as another scrivener
he's like i prefer not to even though
i'm not particular and it's very kind of
anti-dickensian in that sense because
you'd almost think at the end of this he
winds up in prison and if you wanted a
happy ending or was intended to be a
heroic store character there'd be a
rejuvenation at the end he would find
his calling and go do that
and that would be the story about
modernity but he just wants at to do
absolutely nothing even though
apparently he's not opposed to doing any
one job in particular it's the whole lot
of them that he just rejects right
that's a really funny sequence i love
that i think he even offers him a trip
to europe would you like to travel
overseas
i know no thanks it's got no interest in
anything i mean that's that's almost
what you feel like today when you have
all these choices it's hard to be
interested in something but you know at
the end that juxtaposition
to use uh matt's favorite word is uh
uh bartleby uh humanity at the end there
right like like you know bartleby's
death is the death of you know not not
humanity literally but you know oh the
humanity of it you know right there's no
humanity is dead bartleby is dead we
live in this disciplinary society and
there's no hope you know bartleby is the
last column of a ruined temple and he
falls over and you know
it it will die with a whimper not with a
great bang
i think i'll just read the last phrase
the last bit because i had a i had a bit
of trouble i'm not really sure what it
means i'll just read at length if you'll
permit me
um so the narrator hears a rumor that
before bartleby came to work in his
office he worked at the dead letter
office in washington which are
male that can't get to the recipient for
whatever reason and i thought it was
significant that it's in washington i
don't know why but it feels like it is
and he says
when i think over this rumor hardly can
i express the emotions which sees me
dead letters does it not sound like dead
men
conceive a man by nature and misfortune
prone to a pallid hopelessness can any
business seem more fitted to heighten it
than that of continually handling these
dead letters and assorting them for the
flames
for the cart load they are annually
burned sometimes from the folded-out
paper the pale clerk takes a ring the
finger it was meant for perhaps moulders
in the grave a banknote sent in swiftest
charity he whom it would relieve nor
eats nor hungers anymore
pardon for those who died despairing
hope for those who died unhoping good
tidings for those who died stifled by
unrelieved calamities on the errands of
life these letters speed to death ah
bartleby oh the humanity
well what i want to say is what this
room i i actually took this as a sign
and victor maybe you can correct me if
i'm wrong about this that the narrator
is unreliable and still doesn't
understand what is going on if anything
i took this as an affirmation of his
searching to kind of incorporate this
into his cliched mode of thinking uh and
it's still resisting that kind of
interpretation his kind of oh the
humanity at the end of this reminded me
a bit of
helen lovejoy from the simpsons you know
when she goes oh please think of the
children right that's the sense i got
from this like oh the humanity think of
the profundity of this guy who was like
too good for this world or wasn't able
to handle this world which kind of to me
signified he still didn't quite get it
or something
i think there's two interpretations here
either like bartleby got his mind
infected by death and hopelessness by
reading all these letters that were
meant for dead people somehow
or
that
bartleby is just us
like a regular figure just like all
these people who wrote the dead letters
that are all dead everyone's gonna die
just like bartleby did
yeah he's a being unto death as as uh
han points out his design is a negative
being unto death
but it does seem like to your point matt
yeah the narrator is like clutching to
this one biographical detail he's dug up
on bartleby and it's like oh that
explains it all over humanity right
and it's like is it that simple you know
because we also remember like he was the
one describing bartleby this whole time
as like this apparition this cadaverous
entity in my office so like
this is still how he's now constructed
you know his interpretation of bartleby
okay the the dead letter stuff that
resolves it oh the humanity i can go to
sleep now like yeah but that's what's
interesting is like do we buy that do we
accept that that's like the final sort
of like take on that because ostensibly
he could have kept bartleby alive just
by letting him sit in his office and do
his thing
it's by by
as a result of his actions that bartleby
is dead and then he kind of goes at the
end well everybody dies
is that is that what you're getting at
but that's what i mean yeah there's
almost this kind of suit of profundity
to it where he's still searching to kind
of incorporate them into his cliched way
of thinking about things he resists that
so now he kind of looks at this as
the kind of explanatory device that
gives him a way out right it's like oh
he was depressed he read all these
letters think of all the depressed
people out there
kind of like a simon garfunkel song you
know all the lonely people out there oh
the humanity and then i can rest easy
now kind of ruminating on that right
whereas to me there's nothing that
suggested that he was a particularly
melancholic figure in that sense of the
word right again there's almost this
kind of grace or nobility to him that
resists
that interpretation of bridal but for me
at least right that he was just really
sad listen to too much nine and snails
all night long and then just decide he's
gonna starve himself to death right yeah
i mean he does he does want to let
bartle be you know stay in the office
but you know we get the whole
explanation that his his professional
network starts looking at him funny that
who is this who's this unaccountable
character
hovering in your office that won't do
anything we ask
you know he's so he starts to get a bad
reputation for it so you know on errands
of life these letters speed unto death
right i don't know is letter a kind of
interpretation or metaphor for bartleby
or something that just falls out of the
system you know
i think we're going about our business
and certain necessities were enforced on
us
and so bartleby is like one of those
victims of life you know and like so
these letters speed unto death bartleby
is just the element of death and we
feel guilt we feel racked with guilt and
we
layer on these explanations and like you
know we we're carried along by necessity
and sometimes you can you know it's like
it sounds stupid and cliche but you
can't save everybody from the system
that you're trying to fight that's
they're
they're there
those kinds of people like bartleby and
they're the reason we do what we do
we critique we criticize
but you can't save them and you feel
guilt
i really
think that's it just like a dead letter
just like a dead letter bartleby fell
out of the system and just like a dead
letter he has no recipient
recipient as in like a purpose here so
bartleby didn't really have a purpose
here to whom was he sent there was one
point at which the narrator questioned
was this vagrant sent from god to test
my compassion
and then of course his professional
network gets in the way and he has to
cut bart'll be loose but i have this
suspicion too
and here's my interpretation i guess
i have a suspicion that melville saw us
and bartleby and then when you get to
kafka and camus
now we
are truly bartleby we're sent here
like a dead letter
addressed to someone who isn't here to
receive us
very kind of purloined letter like uh
you know it's even we never read the
contents of it but it's there in plain
sight but we don't know what the [ __ ] it
says but everybody seems to be looking
for it but nobody could find it we
should do that one next time with uh
with litvic
an excuse to talk about lacan
too
yeah
it's a good idea
all right let vic any uh conclusions on
how we did as as political philosophy
and philosophy nerds how how did our
analysis go
no i think this was a great discussion
yeah i really like matt's take on the
elite aristocratic kind of bartleby
that's really cool um before we just
been reading lacerdo a lot so like that
kind of a struggle yeah yeah
no i i actually just wanted to uh on a
more personal and don't mention a
bartleby moment that i saw in grad
school once um this is a mutual friend
of ours but i think i was the only one
who saw this in person um we had a
friend in our master's program who
worked as a research assistant for a
prof
no names mentioned but he was a pretty
laid back guy he organized files with
this program for this prof and one
morning in class the prof mentioned this
program to the class and he asked our
friend in front of everyone else
perhaps you'd like to explain how this
program works since you've worked with
it so much and he tosses him the easiest
ball to catch
and our friend just like looks up and
he's like you know never talked in class
before he's like no no that's fine
[Laughter]
and the prop was so
the prophet was so confused because he
didn't even know like you're allowed to
do that like
none of us do that you can just decline
to participate in like this academic
like whatever workplace kind of facade
and yeah so
there are real bartleby's out there and
we've seen some of
them all the humanity
that's hilarious exactly oh the humanity
yeah
all right shall we
sign off or would you say or not to yeah
let's sign off
good one yeah i'm gonna get some
gingernut cakes in me i'm hungry i would
prefer to get a beer we gotta say thank
you very much victor for coming uh
welcome your comments if you want us to
do another book we'll bring them back
yeah we'll do purloined letter we'll do
prolonged letter with lecon that'd be
fun and we'll bring lipvit back or if
you'd like to
write the introduction to our show we're
we're crowdsourcing that now send them
to me somehow and float that out there
all right take care everyone see you
guys this has been what pillpod 5055.
cheers
[Music]
you